[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode of
KL West and today it's a very very
special episode because well a lot of
you guys understand and know that I'm a
huge Marvel fan but I also respect and
love DC characters and today I'm going
to give you one of my most beloved
characters well there's a reimagining of
my most beloved character and I'm not
too familiar with a storyline but let me
give you the background on why I
actually got this statue right Oh gotta
introduce the guy right today I bring to
you XM studios 1/6 scale flash rebirth
alright now we're gonna get into why I
got this um I grew up extremely poor as
a youth and and shout out to my mom I
didn't even know I was that boy he's no
I always had a roof over my head
always have food in my belly and always
had clothes on my back and she worked
her hardest to make sure that my sister
and I maintained those uh those things
in life those necessities so can't never
say I went hungry you know she was
definitely a supermom didn't have a guy
that was around so single-parent
household you know so anybody out there
you absolutely know to struggle um but I
always had strong women in and around my
life starting from my great grandmother
to my gran
mothers to my auntie's - you know my
mother and my sisters you know alone
well though these these the reason why
these strong women was in my life health
you know fundamentally grow me as a man
these things that I learned from them
helped me become the man that I am today
so I say this was saying well you know
he's extremely poor so when I was going
to my grandmother's houses
well one grandmother I would walk rest
in peace to both of them they both pass
never knew my grandfather's they were
both deceased before I came into the
world so when I will go to my
grandmother's house all right my mother
would put me on the bus it was a
straight line bus straight from one you
know bus all the way to my grandmother's
stop so it was probably like a 25 minute
drive if no traffic right so she will
let my grandmother know my grandmother
you know rest her soul will get up and
you know meet me at the bus stop right
so while on the bus you know my mother
told me sitting next to the bus driver
and you're safe there in my head I'm
like okay you know I had to be like 10
to 12 years old
so you know that's best kind of crazy in
this day and age right yeah but okay
wild times I guess um so I sat next to
the bus driver but what I would do is I
will always look out the window and I
know you guys if you have children are
you growing up the
you understand what I'm talking about I
had my imaginary friend my imaginary
friend was the flash all right so when
the bus started he will run from all the
way with me all the way to my
grandmother's house hop and all the
stuff moving really fast and I always
had this affinity for the flash I guess
when reading comic books you try to see
yourself in the characters well I
couldn't fly like Superman didn't have
no website spider-man couldn't crawl the
walls but I can run really fast
especially when I got some new sneakers
I remember I got a pair of red sneakers
and you could not tell me that I was not
the flash well I saw the Statue come up
in XM XM is one of my great studios that
I love I love their work I love their
the craftsmanship I love their attention
to detail I love the packaging I love
the fact that you can get you get a like
a social security number for your statue
just in case something happens
I think XM is a standard in which a lot
of statue companies should follow and
emulate a mimic so what I'll further ado
I give you X some studios flash rebirth
now first off I would like to say thank
you XM for giving me this detailed book
is the assembly book that you will need
to put together this statute oh you
probably said yourself uh well King this
statue doesn't look like you know it's
too large it is probably one of the most
intricate statues I've ever had to put
together alright and and I will probably
take away some points for it because a
lot of these little lightening bolts or
all around the statue and you have to
put them in pegs and they're not
magnetized so some of them don't stick
like this one now you have to come to
the choice which yourself with are you
going to use some glue
put it in or not but watching the flash
TV show they run on that treadmill and
you see the Speed Force behind him and
he's coming through the wall this flash
is so amazing I mean I really can't say
too many things you know negative about
it other than the fact that I wish the
pegs was magnetized the level of detail
on this test statue is so immense from
the shoes down to the metallic paint to
the vortex that he wanted to do to the
treadmill that he's on the treadmill is
magnificent to the statue scope itself
the the fact that they got the sensation
of motion in the character that alone
made this a plus for me made it
automatic purchase now I know a lot of
guys don't you know carry 1/6 scale and
I feel you and I understand hey you know
god bless say less right I love the
statue and I like this the fact that I
got this little box right so I was like
oh what's in the box what's in the box
well this was in the box a little plaque
and it has a little stand a little
kickstand to it and it sits there and
had the blue sticker on it I took the
blue stick off actually to see the
metallic part to it and it is great it's
it's a definite great piece to it sigh
XM used to give you a coin and that coin
was how can I say it was it was fabulous
I hope they go back to the coins but if
they're not I will definitely take this
little plaque well this is the part of
the video where I'm going to ask you to
like follow and subscribe and also hit
the join button hit that hit that joy
button do you know what a join button is
there join button is right below
that way you can watch all the
background videos all blooper videos
everything that is wif Kos also lords of
gaming net also iron Lords podcasts and
the last word with law Cognito and
advances you know it's a whole lot of
material and stuff that we have that's
when you join the realm tons of video
and then if you go to log net which is
loads of gaming dotnet you can watch a
lot of old episodes of kos combat talk
with the king attics hard gaming reviews
and also read a lot of opinion pieces a
lot of reviews and a lot of new tech
stuff that's going on in this gaming
streets so listen stick around watch
this video all this statue has to offer
and you can also watch the unbox and a
listen to some cool music until next
week when I bring you another statue
that's gonna make you think about
jumping in and collecting and to
everybody that started collecting just
because you watch this thank you that's
all I look for and stay collecting
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]